Let's continue looking at some other variables so we can better
understand our users in our sample data set. This time I'm going
to examine the distribution of tenure, or how many days someone has
been using Facebook. I'm also going to start introducing color to jazz
up our plots a little bit. To do that I'm going to
use the color and the fill parameter. Now, I'm not going to explain
this code in detail. Check out the instructor notes for an explanation
of this code. There's also a link to ggplot's themes to learn
about all the different adjustments besides color that you can make. Now,
if this code has thrown you for a loop, I don't want
you to focus on it too much, you can really just ignore
it. I'll typically include it as the second line of parameters inside of
qplot. Running this code, you can see we get a nice histogram.
And again, here the histogram has defaulted to the automatic bin width. I'm
going to make one last adjustment and set it for ourselves. By setting
the bin width equal to 30, we can see we get a finer
view of the distribution. Let's see if you have
a handle on histograms and bin width. We're going to see
if you can change the distribution in this next
programming exercise. In it, you're going to be creating a histogram
of tenured that's measured in years, rather than in
days. You'll also want to think about an appropriate bin
width for the data. 30 here makes sense, since
I'm measuring days, and 30 days is about a month.